I want to go to the phone's a little
early this week because of the
thanksgiving holiday will go to the
phones early 617 830 for 750 is the
number we will take our first call name
and town always great to know where
you're calling from oh hey great uh
money de la poem from Atlanta um love
y'all show great stuff I didn't think I
get picked up you got so um anyways yeah
so the question I had was um with Donald
Trump being you know president-elect and
all that hoopla yeah that all I'm I was
curious what you think that could
potentially happen I was hearing that um
Rudy Giuliani could potentially be the
UM like head of the department of
justice or something and if they do that
state nationwide stop and frisk like for
me I'm a African American fellow I've
already gotten a possession charge for
marijuana like last year and I was just
curious how like what do you think of
the possibility of that actually being
invoked listen I would like to think
that it's not very likely although you
know very unlikely things have happened
during this election so I think that
that we can't really say for sure that
that it wouldn't happen i'm curious what
was your when you were stopped and and
you had this possession charge what were
the circumstances that led up to it it
was very silly i had some you know
marijuana on me i got i was driving my
headlight was out and he i was kind of
my own mistake but i got pulled over
officer came to the window that he uh he
literally just looked and said hey I
need to search you for weapons and me
being naive I was just like oh yes sir
okay yeah go ahead and patting me down
grab the weed and threw me into the
system essentially yeah yeah and now
yeah go ahead done well the head of the
Department of Justice is the Attorney
General and the appointment for that
yesterday or the day before was jeff
Sessions so I guess the good news is
that you're not going to be seeing Rudy
Giuliani in charge of the Justice
Department but we're gonna be seeing
jeff Sessions who said that uh good
people don't smoke marijuana yeah and uh
that that's maybe a bigger concern hate
now I'm curious as far as the being
pulled over thing I you know I'm not
exactly sure what the circumstances were
and if there was such like a probable
cause scenario but would you if that
happened again would you now say I don't
consent to searches am I being detained
type of thing yes that's the that's what
the UH that's probably what I would do
just I mean take it as far as I can and
then you know try to fight it as much as
I can to be honest i'm personally
graduating uh with computer science
degree so i'll be fine you know but
there's a lot of people out there that
aren't going to be fine you a fan like
they don't have resources to fight this
or move somewhere else where it's got
you know it's legal or something you
know something like that yeah so no
doubt about it listen it's not looking
great in so far as the Attorney General
will likely be a person who thinks you
you're fundamentally not a good person
if you smoke pot but uh you know maybe
at some point we'll find some kind of
silver lining with regard to this and I
think state legalization
decriminalization is is a good thing and
that something but we don't know how the
federal government will decide to abide
by or ignore those uh those state
decisions all right thank you so much
for the call I really really appreciate
it